So thank you for watching today's course.
Hopefully you got a lot of mileage out of the different tips and tricks that we have
presented today.
There's a lot of additional resources that you can dig into, whether it be in the slate
architecture, the invalidation boxes, anything to do with UMG designer.
There's a few good additional resources to dig into there if you'd like to follow those
links.
And then we've talked about optimizations based on textures, meshes, materials.
We talked about the different view modes that are available in Unreal Engine, and also a
few different tools you can use to get you started on your journey.
So thank you very much for watching today.
Hopefully it was a lot of in-depth knowledge to at least point you in the right direction
of how to start optimizing your scenes.
So thank you for watching and we'll see you on the next course.